et on a entendu la voix qui m'a dit ok
ok
[Musique]
toi merci merci
wes issues des bases et rôti oui oui à
travers une caméra
non non non mais c'est comme ça ouais
sur quelqu'un de connu ce que tous ces
gens d'y arriver sur ce plateau
non pas parce que ce plat toi tu viens
d'arriver ces pages internet sur ce
plateau c'est que c'est kelly non c'est
quoi c'est pas isabelle entrevoit plus
aux soirées mon âme âge non je suis avec
cyril hanouna
mais oui mais là on a fait une soirée
chocola et du coup j'ai ton band obligé
de mordre dans n'importe quoi merci à
travers cabinet enderle un petit truc
c'était une tentative de ressembler à
claude françois est en délire c'est plus
gilles verdez à et plus vers des jouets
cette bourgade est ce que cloclo mx fait
pour travaux je suis sûr que c'est votre
style en mai moi j'adorais le père adore
le fils
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qu'ils adorent qu'est-ce qui
n'alerte à voir comment tu as dit avant
ça va possiblement possible faut faire
un choix
non non ça va pas être possible c'était
balancer sérieusement qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'il redonne foi en fuite
on avait fait aussi un jeu de ouija avec
donc les entités de lola qui vient de se
manifester et répondre à des questions
qu'on leur pose et moi j'ai eu quand
même un contact assez privilégiés avec
une de ces entités
on lui a demandé si elle avait un
message personnel pour moi on a attendu
et puis finalement ça s'est dessinée
j'ai on a entendu la voix qui m'a dit ok
[Rires]
non non c'était bien des supporters
marseillais vous [ __ ] pour tous dès
vous a dit oui et ben justement c'est
bien j'ai envie de te faire un bisou
allez encore jeune en braquant mais ça
va merci merci maman merci papa merci ça
me touche beaucoup que tu sois là
[Musique]